there's people our record labels that
are looking for this sort of thing
they're looking for artists that while
they're doing a show and everyone knows
the words to their stuff and they're not
signed right so a few you know some
people spotted me some ANR's and some
managers reaching out and it's a small
industry
so if sort of one label is talking about
something too late was then you can kind
of go to a third one guy hey they're
gonna offer me a deal do you want to
have a meeting type of thing um
so yeah my stuff started to catch on and
I was taking these meetings I'm in my
junior year at Duke I'm flying in New
York I mean with Craig and Julie at
Atlantic you know I mean with Barry
Weiss at RCA and I'm going back to do
again I'm in finals week you know and
I'm writing this paper and my manager
calls me and he says you gotta go back
to New York I can't go back to New York
what I need to do is finish his paper
meet cuz oh hi I'm behind the eight ball
a little bit here man and he goes yeah
go back to New York jay-z wants to meet
you I wrote jay-z didn't wanna meet me
man don't mess with me he goes jay-z
must have meet you
I go okay book the fly and I believe I
didn't believe I thought I was gonna go
and they would say hey we're sorry he's
busy today you're gonna meet with
someone so that's why I actually does
that happens all the time like if you've
been around entertainment that's stuck
it goes that way
yeah and I would that's yeah that's what
I expected me so I didn't tell any
friends you know and I get on the plane
I go to to New York do you think sorry
to interrupt you but do you think that
impetus like I have to go even though I
have a final was in part informed by
this sense that you had made this
mistake in going to Duke while Big Sean
and those other guys were
gettin signed like you didn't want to
miss another perhaps yeah I had a deal
with myself in those years which was if
there's any scent on the trail
you gotta go so labor times where you
know like the first time I was supposed
to meet with cannon who did my mixtape I
drove to Atlanta and he something got
messed up like the guy connecting us and
he was busy and I went there for no
reason but I had to deal with myself
there was sent on the trail you got to
go
and what's the ambition level look like
at this point then or now bad high well
I tell you what change it for me was was
knowing Sean you know cuz I met Sean and
then Sean really got his deal done with
Kanye and he was going in the studio
with Pharrell he's gone in the studio
with the dream he was me Madonna and
this was a guy that I used to free start
with you know we go back and forth and
it's hip-hop
I always thought I was better than him
not not just you know I thought better
than everyone and so this thing that
seems so far-fetched before was just I
knew what's gonna happen now I go Sean
did it I'm next
it's happening you know it's I just knew
yeah and but I tell him all the time and
it he really changed my life twice once
I just living his life in that way show
me what was really possible and then I
again when you get told me read those
books right yeah and and you know by
living it yeah in the studio that day
and so Jay so your honor you go to New
York yeah and Sean oh he helped out
somebody a year before the jay-z meeting
we're in Detroit and Kanye's playing
going the dark tour okay
and Sean gets like guest listed 20
tickets so it's like all of our buddies
are there man
Sean brings all of us
backstage and meet Kanye and then it's
like three months later Shawn calls me
up and he goes Calle is playing MSG
tonight you want to come
jay-z's supposed to be there I say I do
ramen Michigan right phone is silent msg
Madison Square yeah
phone is silent for like 10 seconds my
gosh probably Booker would play good he
goes yeah yeah you should ah so we go
there I go to pick up the tickets at
will call
I'm gonna get back to the next meeting I
got I go to MSG I go to wheel cause I am
Mike Posner tickets supposed to be here
and they go we have no tickets for you
Dane are you sure Michael maybe Michael
no tickets for you I call Sean I go man
there's no tickets here for me he goes
okay just meet me at the studio then I'm
at the studio at Kanye I go upgrade like
thank God there were no ticket so we go
to a studio it gives me address he meets
his downstairs and always in these nicer
studios there's a lounge which is like a
room for the managers to wait while arts
meeting so he goes just wait in the
lounge so he goes in the studio and you
can hear the music they're playing and I
hear one of the songs I did was Sean
playing whoa
and I know Kanye West is listening to
this track who knows that I produced are
saying the Khorasan and Sean wrapped on
and I I'm freaking out because I know if
he likes this thing this could change my
life like for real for real like so a
song is I see a bunch of people walk by
the lounge towards the elevator I go I
guess we're leaving now so I walk I
follow them out
and Shawn's there Connie's there Shawn
goes kya this is mike posner he made the
song they I just played you kind guys oh
cool
it gives me a fist bite and then there's
another silence five-second 10 seconds
and very courageously I ask did you like
it it kind of goes No
Oh No he goes it he goes maybe maybe it
could be for Lupe it's not right for
Shawn and then he said one of the
coolest analogies or he goes I'm sorry
Shawn bumped it you said it I had to
spike it meaning like he played it you
asked me I had to tell you the truth I'm
like and then I'm thinking like how do
you think of that that could you
appreciate the honesty
like on one level didn't feel I want to
be very clear it did not feel rude at
all uh-huh because you meet too many
people and it all man I smoked up yeah
yeah it was just honest have you Jonas
have you and it helped me it helped me
because I knew in my heart I had better
stuff in me uh-huh
and so we got in this elevator and all I
wanted to do is make music I didn't want
to quit I wanted to make more and that
six months pass I keep doing my thing I
keep plugging the stuff starts to catch
on so now now I'm in finals week uh-huh
six months later a tape I don't remember
eight months later and I'm in jay-z's
office I got my laptop I'm fumbling with
the aux cable I get that thing in there
I'm nervous
I play cooler than me and jay-z goes
like this he was just like squish his
face yeah just like in a way that you're
not sure if he likes it no I you know
he's into I knew he loved it I knew he
loved it and we had this incredible
meeting here I felt like he really under
to me I was there like two hours which
in hindsight I'm like that was
ridiculous and I'm about to leave and I
just had this inkling I go can't play
one more song he says yeah so I plugged
my laptop back in I play him who knows
same song and he went nuts he goes - he
goes I can't believe you almost left
without playing this for me he got you
know don't ever forget to play that song
[Music]